et si au pied du sapin le père noël
déposer des sacs en tissu ou des
pochettes des produits artisanaux en
série très limitée
la créatrice nathalie de la ville et on
multiplie les marchés de noël les
marchés de noël me permettent de
rencontrer mes clientes d'aller
face
au public d'avoir les remontées
d'informations et puis des réactions de
d'éventuels clients sur les produits
donc c'est à la fois moteur et c'est
assez satisfaisant
bienvenue dans mon atelier donc c'est le
sous sol de ma maison
un atelier versailles est lancée en 2013
nathalie de la ville et on y crée exposé
sur rendez vous depuis cinq ans près de
4000 pièces ont vu le jour
nathalie utilise sa première aiguille à
l'âge de 8 ans tout est fait main tout
est fait chaque pièce sort de l'atelier
sortie si je suis la seule à coudre donc
toutes les pochettes pour moi qui les ai
faites du motif au tissu la versaillaise
pense chaque détail un sac lui demande
cinq heures de travail
elle crée également pochette et
accessoires de mode pour les bijoux
c'est une affaire de famille
les bijoux se sont développés parce que
ma fille aînée s'est prise d'affection
pour les perles et s'est mise à plein
d'idées
donc elle s'est mise à développer cette
activité là aussi est comment dire à
partir de janvier elle va passer autant
entrepreneurs de façon à pouvoir devenir
mon fournisseur
nathalie de la ville et on propose ses
produits essentiellement aux ventes
privées par les réseaux sociaux et le
bouche à oreille
ses créations sont envoyés dans toute la
france et à l'étranger
je peux m'adapter aux besoins de la
cliente c'est à dire que si elle veut un
sac plus grand plus petit des ans plus
grande
quelque chose qui soit plutôt porté
épaule cette année j'ai fait surtout des
portes épaules pour pour l'hiver parce
que on m'avait dit voilà on aimerait
bien pouvoir le mettre sur nos manteaux
territoire à laquelle moi regarder
quelques produits sont aussi disponibles
dans une boutique à versailles nathalie
il propose une cinquantaine de créations
c'est très important d'être en boutique
en plus des marchés
comment dire qu'ils sont relativement
saisonniers parce que
les événements ont lieu en général en
fin d'année ou au moment de mars avril
mai juin ça me permet d'avoir la
possibilité de rencontrer aussi des gens
ailleurs que chez moi je peux pas ouvrir
l'atelier non plus à tout le monde ça me
permet de m'inscrire dans
dans un univers puisque françoise
travail par par univers tout et on n'a
pas de l'espace particulièrement dédié
on est un peu partout dans la boutique
des créations dans une large palette de
couleurs pour se faire plaisir hein ça
coûte entre 15 et 70 euros pour les
boucles d'oreilles compter de 12 à 45
euros